有没有这种感觉,你只写一句提示词,一个女生在海边走,模型还挺稳定,但你一旦加入细节,二十七岁,短发,卡其色,风衣,逆光,慢推镜头,表情克制,电影感,黄昏海岸,她开始乱夹细节,丢设定,甚至画面崩掉
为什么?提示词越具体,模型反而越不听话,因为你的提示词没有进行分层控制
这不是玄学,也不是提示词写的不好,如果你做过几次AB测试就会发现,背后其实是一个很理性的工程问题
生成模型不是在逐条执行命令,而是在有限计算部署里做约束满足
我们先把Prompt的服从度翻译成技术一点的话,它指的是文本条件能在多大程度上约束生成结果的语意、构图、运动和风格
对于视频生成系统来说,Prompt通常会先被文本编码器压缩成一组向量,再通过交叉注意力、条件引导等机制影响趋躁过程
注意,这里有个关键点,模型看到的不是一张执行清单,而是一组高维语义相量
它不是像导演助理一样逐条核对,短发有没有,风衣有没有,镜头有没有慢推,而是在概率分布里寻找一个既符合文本条件
又看起来像真实视频的结果,所以条件越多,问题就越像多目标优化
你要求角色年龄、发型、服装、镜头焦段、运镜方式、情绪表演同时成立
每一项都会占有模型的表达能力和注意力资源
更麻烦的是,这些条件之间可能并不完全兼容
比如,35毫米广角感和面部特写可能在构图上互相拉扯
逆光剪影和清晰表情在光照上互相冲突
模型并不是故意忽略你,而是在冲突条件里自动做取舍
各种提示词约束开始互相抢资源
在视频声称里,这个抢资源主要发生在三层
第一层,是文本编码的压缩损失
Prompt在场,最后都要进入文本编码器
长距并列修饰,抽象风格词和具体物体词会被压到同一个语异空间里
模型可能抓住海边,女声,电影感这些强信号
却弱化卡其色,27岁,表情克制这些细立度信号
第二层,是条件引导和画面质量的张力
很多扩散系统会采用像CFG的条件引导
把生成结果往文本描述上拉
引导太弱,画面自然,但不够听话
引导太强,语意更贴近Prompt
但容易带来过饱和,纹理噪声,肢体异常,面部不稳定
就像遛狗,绳子太松,它会乱跑
绳子太紧,它又会走得变形
第三层,是视频比图片多了时间维度
图片只需要一阵成立
视频还要让角色、服装、光线、背景和运动在几十帧里连续成立
当你在Prompt里塞进大量的局部细节时
模型不仅要把它们逐一生成出来
还要让它们在几十帧里始终保持一致,不发生飘移
所以,提示词越细越不听话,本质不是越详细越差
而是未经分层的详细会让模型同时承担太多目标
如果你想让模型提高服从度,可以按三个层级写
第一,先写硬约数
主体、场景、动作、镜头目标
比如短发女性在黄昏海边缓慢行走,镜头从中景缓慢推进
第二,再写少量关键细节,服装、光线、情绪
比如卡其色风衣、逆光边缘光、表情克制
第三,最后写风格
不要让风格词淹没结构词
比如写实电影质感、自然运动、稳定时序
如果一个镜头里必须控制很多细节,就不要指望
一条Prompt全包
更稳的方法是拆镜头、拆阶段、线索主体和构图
再做风格和运动
必要使用参考图、收尾针、遮罩或后期矫正来分担Prompt的压力
真正的Prompt的强控不是写得更长更细
而是让模型知道先听谁的、后听谁的
哪些绝对不能错
懂一点底层原理,画面就会越来越听话
我们下期见